et on accueille le nouveau président
notre conseil national monsieur jean
leonetti merci monsieur le président
quand cher laurent permets moi de saluer
les personnalités qui sont autour de toi
d'abord au président du sénat mon ami
gérard larcher qui elle redonner des
couleurs en gagnant les sénatoriales
contre toute attente du pouvoir actuel
christian christian qui gère ce groupe à
la fois d'une main de fer mais avec un
énorme gant de velours et qu'il le fait
j'allais dire mon cher christian à
l'ancienne voilà à l'ancienne mais loyal
bruno merci merci de faire porter les
valeurs au coeur de notre mouvement
le groupe majoritaire au sénat te
reconnais comme un chef et qui porte des
valeurs et puis merci à bernard vous
pouvez applaudir aussi bruno quand même
à bernard accoyer ont été longtemps
complices et dans un groupe
parlementaire et il a deux défauts que
j'ai c'est qu'il est pragmatique et
qu'il est médecin et qu'il est loyal
c'est un défi supplémentaire il a porté
le parti dans une période difficile dans
le remercie de son action messieurs les
ministres messieurs les parlementaires
chers amis mes propos donc commence
obligatoirement par un remerciement
je ne m'attendais pas de me trouver à se
place et je le dois à laurent wauquiez
merci de m'avoir sollicité sur ce poste
merci à vous tous de ne pas l'avoir
contestées merci de ne pas avoir été
candidat merci de m'avoir permis d'être
là aujourd'hui
voilà mon cher laurent merci de cet
honneur et cette confiance
j'accepte cette mission avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé
parce que il ya plusieurs raisons à ça
d'abord parce qu'elle est synonyme de
diversité
chacun le sait je viens de l'udf et je
suis membre fondateur de l'ump puis des
républicains je continue à penser que
nous avons beaucoup plus de choses à
mettre en commun et qui nous rassemble
que deux sujets qui nous divisent je me
souviens déjà de cette période assez
ancienne déjà dans lequel il y avait un
groupe udf et un groupe rpr à
l'assemblée nationale et quand on
prenait la parole en disait je prends la
parole au nom de l'opposition puisque
nous étions dans l'opposition à cette
époque là et on le disait au nom du
groupe udf et rpr parce que nous nous
étions rendus compte qu'effectivement
nous avions les mêmes mots les mêmes
convictions les mêmes combats je crois
la diversité de ce mouvement qui est un
gage d'une idée mais combats ont
toujours été ceux de ma famille
politique
vos combats sont les miens mais combats
sont les vôtres c'est une famille
politique
dans une famille politique dans une
famille tout court de temps en temps on
s'entend
complètement complètement il ya une
génération qui contestent la la suivante
il ya la génération qui monte qui compte
est celle qui précède c'est assez
classique et c'est assez normal mais moi
j'ai le sens de la famille et le sens de
la famille sy qu'on est ensemble on
gagne ensemble on perd ensemble et on
continue ainsi je n'oublie pas une
seconde que lorsque avec beaucoup d'amis
qui aujourd'hui prennent brillamment le
relais on a débattu des lois de
bioéthique de fin de vie on a parlé de
valeurs et si nous avons emporté
ensemble la conviction de l'ensemble de
l'hémicycle
nous l'avons fait sur des convictions et
jamais sur des compromissions et j'ai eu
le soutien à ce moment là de tous ceux
et toutes celles qui viennent des
libéraux qui viennent des centristes qui
vient des radicaux qui viennent des
gaullistes
parce que nous sentions que c'était le
coeur et l'âme de notre parti parce que
c'était le coeur et l'âme de notre pays
merci à vous tous pour ce soutien la
diversité bien sûr ça n'exclut pas la
loyauté la loyauté ce n'est pas la
fidélité la fidélité c'est celle du
chien à la laisse courte à qui on ne
laisse aucune possibilité qui obéit aux
maîtres ou au gourou la loyauté c'est
défendre au sein de sa famille son point
de vue de le faire loyalement
d'argumenter d'essayer de convaincre et
à la fin accepter la règle de la
majorité
c'est ça la loyauté
on me pose souvent la question et on me
la posent plus beaucoup maintenant
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas en marche vous
le l'ancien centriste l'humaniste vous
devriez être en marche
la réponse est simple parce que chez ces
gens là monsieur on ne débat pas on
obéit
[Applaudissements]
mon cher laurent
tu cèdes amitié ancienne et profonde que
je te porte mais le matin quand je me
réveille ou quand je me rase devant la
glace je me dis pas que pense le chef je
me dis simplement comment pouvons-nous
ensemble à tes côtés et derrière toi
redresser notre mouvement et le
reconstruire
enfin s'il fallait un argument de plus
pour dire pourquoi je ne suis pas en
main ce j'ajouterai qu'un centriste et
plus largement un humaniste ne peut se
satisfaire d'un gouvernement qui prend
l'argent des plus modestes pour alléger
les impôts des plus fortunés d'un
président qui pense qu'il ya des
personnes dans ce pays qui ne sont rien
et d'un président qui dit que mon pays
ma france n'a pas de culture propre la
deuxième raison de mon engagement et il
n'étonnera personne
c'est que je considère que le front
national est un danger pour notre pays
il est dangereux parce que je connais
l'histoire de l'extrême droite en france
et je sais à quoi ça peut m'aider
il est dangereux aussi parce que son
projet économique de sortie de l'euro
serait la ruine de la france et la ruine
des français des épargnants comme des
salariés et je pense que c'est toi
laurent toi qui est le meilleur rempart
contre les extrêmes pourquoi les
extrêmes existent ils se nourrissent du
mépris et quelquefois de l'arrogance des
élites et des dirigeants vis-à-vis des
inquiétudes et de misère du peuple les
extrêmes se nourrissent aussi de ces
paroles moralisatrices est impuissante
aux ont donc accepté le parti de ne pas
choisir le parti unique de ne pas
choisir la pensée unique de dire les
choses
osons nous opposer à un gouvernement qui
n'appliquent tout simplement pas le
programme qui était le nôtre
osons être cette voix dissonante dans le
concert des louanges d'helmand et des
ralliements opportuniste ozon ne pas
ressentir une admiration sans bornes
à tous les actes que fait le président
de la république au zoo enfin ne pas
s'excuser s'expliquer avec les gens qui
venaient de notre formation politique
pour leur dire maintenant j'y vais pas
non je reste dans ma famille c'est eux
qui devraient plutôt se justifier de
dire pourquoi ils sont partis de la
famille politique est la nôtre la
troisième raison du fait que j'ai
accepté cet honneur c'est que nous
devons reconstruire la maison et on
reconstruit la maison avec un projet
nous avons les fondations elles sont
simples
ce sont nos valeurs comment on
reconstruit ce projet d'abord en
acceptant d'être lucide et modeste
peut-être ça nous changera un petit peu
ça nous donnera le loisir de constater
que nous avons perdu deux élections
majeures et pourtant promise et que nous
avons perdu une imperdable
on peut trouver les raisons de ce
terrible échec dans l'affrontement
stérile des personnes aidées et des
affrontements de chapelle
quand la trahison des anges dans les
calomnies des autres ce n'est pas faux
mais nous devons aussi avoir la lucidité
les amis
dans cette famille politique
[Applaudissements]
mes chers amis valérie pécresse fait
partie de notre boulot
cependant je souhaiterais qu'elle rentre
avec une discrétion qui s'impose dans
une situation pareille
mes amis je vous demande d' accueillir
très chaleureusement avec des
applaudissements nourris
valérie pécresse merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
oh
bienvenue galerie dans ta maison dans ta
famille chez nous
[Applaudissements]
eh bien oui nous avons très probablement
déçu une partie de notre électorat nous
les avons déçu d'abord parce que nous
n'avons pas toujours fait après ce que
nous avions dit avant et nous avons déçu
aussi parce que peut-être avons-nous
manqué d'idées nouvelles
nous les avons déçu et lorsque l'on dit
après que l'on fait après des choses que
l'on avait dit avant je vous demande
d'accueillir chaleureusement monsieur
edouard balladur premier ministre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous êtes vraiment le reflet du peuple
de france rebelle brillant mais
rassembler voilà
renier sa parole c'est toujours une
blessure
c'est une blessure pour celui qui le
fait et c'est une blessure pour celui
qui l'entend
nietzsche à une phrase terrible il dit
ce qui bouleverse ça n'est pas que tu
aies menti mais c'est que jamais plus je
ne pourrais te croire il ya un bel
exemple en ce moment le président de la
république à notre dame des landes a
bafoué sa parole il a bafoué la
démocratie
il n'a pas fou et les élus locaux il a
bafoué un territoire
il a bafoué l'autorité eh bien je pense
que lorsque l'on ment de manière si
grossière et un intervalle 6 courts et
bien on fait de la mauvaise politique
ça n'est pas la politique nouvelle parce
que si c'est ça la politique nouvelle
franchement on sait comment elle s'est
passée dans l'ancien temps je voudrais
aussi vous dire la conviction que nous
devons désormais porter un projet
nouveau nouveau ça veut dire que il ya
un certain nombre de tabous qui vont
tomber ce matin laurent wauquiez disait
faut que les idées viennent de partout
de tous les territoires
il faut que nous osions ensemble faire
en sorte que ce que nous avons décidé
puisse être remise en cause c'est le
débat d'idées ce débat d'idées il doit
se tenir ici dans le conseil national
vous êtes le parlement du parti
vous êtes le parlement qui doit faire
émerger ces idées et personne n'a de
détient la vérité et donc chacun et
chacune d'entre vous portent cette
parcelle de vérité qui doit revenir ici
pour un débat vous annette est porteur
vous en serez les acteurs vous en serez
les ambassadeurs vous en serez les
défenseurs de notre nouveau projet je
suis sûr qu'on pense pas tous la même
chose j'ai même eu peut-être un peu le
sentiment que c'était le kayak cinq
minutes mais pour autant
les idées qui dérangent doivent
apparaître des propositions innovantes
doivent répondre à un monde qui
apparemment est nouveau les jeunes
générations ont le devoir de s'y coller
et les générations comme la mienne ont
le devoir de les y aider
nous devons tracer de nouvelles voies
repousser de nouvelles frontières ou
couvrir tous les champs des possibles
parce que c'est la seule voix de
l'espérance
nous avons bien sûr depuis trop
longtemps ccdh oser oser dire autre
chose que ce que l'on croyait qu'on
attendait de nous on voulait pas fâché
surtout pas fâcher la fois la famille
mais même pas fâcher les médias mais
quelquefois même pas fâché l'adversaire
parce qu après tout peut-être
l'adversaire
si je lui dis qu'il a raison peut-être
qu'ils soient moins de méchant
franchement est ce qu'il n'ya pas une
petite remise en cause de tout ça
aujourd'hui balayé comme nous l'avons
été dans les élections précédentes
nous avons le devoir de l'audace et ce
devoir de l'audace il doit être le
combat des idées qui se substitue au
combat des chefs
je vous le demande
je vous le demande parce que c'est la
seule voie pour que nous puissions
porter un projet innovant et rassembleur
quelles sont les valeurs nous les avons
écrit ensemble lorsqu'on a formé l'ump
qui ont pas ça c'est ici que s'est formé
l'ump c'est un bel endroit c'était un
bon moment
et si on refaisait une renaissance
si on faisait une renaissance sur les
valeurs on était plusieurs à écrire de
toutes les formations politiques
qu'est ce que c'est nos valeurs il y
avait un grand jeune homme vêtu de noir
qui écrivait et qui faisait la synthèse
de nos propos ce jeune homme était
brillant s'appelait laurent wauquiez
laurent comme je te vois dit gentillesse
de comme j'ai encore l'oreille très très
fine à gérard effectivement c'est moi
qui ai reçu ce président à l'assemblée
nationale ce jeune huron comme il le
disait à l'époque voilà je vais donner
un conseil ne te laisse pas faire par
les aînés je viens d'un conseil appuie t
conviction jusqu'au bout 20 celle là au
moins il l'a suivi et je le remercie
oui nous sommes le parti de la liberté
de la responsabilité de l'autorité et à
propos de l'autorité je voudrais que
nous pensions très clairement que
l'autorité ce n'est pas contraire à la
fraternité à l'humanité
l'autorité elle protège le faible elle
protège le vulnérables elle établit
l'ordre juste elle ne donne la ligne de
l'ordre républicain
la france je vous le dis avec beaucoup
de sincérité
elle n'est pas coupable elle n'est pas
coupable de l'enfant qui va devenir
délinquants ou terroristes elle est
coupable de ne pas avoir assumé son
autorité pour que cet enfant là ne
puisse pas avoir le chemin de la
république et le chemin des valeurs
relisez la lettre de camus camus et prix
nobel est la première des choses à
laquelle il pense et c'est normal c'est
à sa mère mais la deuxième chose a qui
pensent deuxième personne à qui y pense
c'est à son instituteur et lui dit sans
votre main affectueuse jamais le petit
enfant pauvre que j'étais n'aurait pu
arriver là où je suis eh bien
méditons cette phrase la république doit
avoir une main affectueuse et ferme
elle doit guider elle doit sanctionner
elle doit aussi promouvoir l'autorité
c'est aussi l'humanité
quand on est faible et quand on est
pauvre c'est l'autorité qui protège et
c'est le lac 6
qui expose la laïcité ça protège les
femmes dans les banlieues
ça protège les les jeunes dans les
quartiers
ça protège nos enfants à l'école la
laïcité c'est notre force
relisez pascal pascal deal la force sans
la justice c'est la brutalité et même la
tyrannie mais la justice sans la force
c'est l'impuissance et bien nous nous
sommes la force juste des lois de la
république
et chaque fois que la loi de la
république et bafouées chaque fois que
l'autorité du policier du gendarme du
maître d'école du pompier
chaque fois que toute autorité est mise
à bas c'est la france qui recule c'est
la démocratie qui recule c'est nos
valeurs beaucoup avec un peu d'orgueil
je dis que je suis d'une famille
humaniste mais l'humaniste c'est un
combat c'est un combat contre
l'intolérance
ce n'est pas la tolérance de
l'intolérable la droite républicaine
doit porter ce projet humaniste et
social d'abord elle n'a pas honte de ce
qu'elle a fait elle a fait la sécurité
sociale elle a instauré le droit de vote
à 18 ans elle donne le droit aux femmes
à avorter elle a donné des bases des
lois bioéthiques
elle a ouvert le champ des lois sur le
handicap
pourquoi faudrait-il aujourd'hui que
l'on s'excuse de prendre le mot social
où le mot humaniste il n'appartient pas
à d'autres il est à l'intérieur de notre
formation politique parce que il se base
sur l'autorité la droite peut-être
sociale et humaniste et tu l'a très bien
dit en chaire laurent la télévision sans
tomber dans le travers du filet d'eau
tiède du consensus mou enfin je suis
engagé auprès de toi parce que nous
aimons tous les deux l'europe et c'est
un sujet c'est un sujet parce que on a
toujours l'impression qu'il ya les pros
et les antis vous êtes pour ou contre
l'europe quelles questions idiotes
qu'est-ce question binaire idiote c'est
un sujet majeur et les prochaines
échéances électorales
c'est l'europe et donc nous devons nous
mettre en ordre de bataille
thème noter que j'ai pas dire marche
quand même un ordre de bataille pour
faire en sorte que le projet notre
projet européen
[Applaudissements]
mon cher laurent j'ai eu la chance de te
succéder au ministère des affaires
européennes nous y avons mené la même
politique
le ministre d'état qui était ministre
affaires étrangères s'appelait juppé le
ministre premier ministre s'appelait
fillon le président de la république
s'appelait nicolas sarkozy il y avait à
cette époque là pas dix mille voix pour
parler de l'europe
il y avait une seule voix c'était la
voix de la france
c'était une europe que nous défendions
comme une robe des frontières sûres pour
éviter les flux migratoires incontrôlés
et réformer schengen
est ce que tout le monde s'en souvient
bien est ce que toutes les écuries
politiques peuvent se souvenir que nous
avons porté le même projet et puisque
monsieur le premier ministre vous nous
fait l'honneur d'être présent qui a dit
qu'il fallait resserrer plusieurs
cercles
oui c'est edouard balladur qui a le
premier pensé qu'il fallait resserrer
des cercles avec le cercle des
fondateurs et puis le cercle de feu avec
qui ont développé la démocratie et des
échanges économiques
la première semaine où j'ai été nommé
aux affaires européennes j'ai cité un
libre mais alors surtout surtout ça
c'est un scandale
l'éloge des frontières ça passait à peu
près parce que c'était régis debray qui
l'avait écrit donc ça atténue est un
tout petit peu la violence de dire que
les frontières pouvaient être considérés
il disait et si l'absence de frontières
était un leurre une fuite et même une
lâcheté
la frontière est ce qui donne du sens à
l'autre et qui permet l'hospitalité de
l'autre qui est différent de moi et que
j'accueille le mur interdit le passage
de la frontière le réguler et bien si
nous pensions les frontières comme une
zone des changes et par comres une
passoire
peut-être aurions-nous une idée de ce
que nous voulons dans une europe ouverte
et dans une robe rassembler les visions
à la même époque que nous étions contre
l' élargissement sans fin d'une europe
sans projet et que la turquie n'avait
pas sa place dans l'union européenne
est ce que le fait de le dire
aujourd'hui peut apparaître comme un
discours trop de droite ou est ce que
c'est un discours de bon sens nous
disions que nous voulions une europe qui
protège notre économie et empêche les
produits étrangers de concurrencer
déloyalement nos entreprises surtaxés
surexposé et sur réglementée personne à
ce moment là non plus trouvé à redire à
ce propos à cette époque on demandait
pas alstom à siemens pour faire plaisir
à l'allemagne
à cette époque lorsqu on discutait avec
nos amis allemands en discuter avec une
certaine fermeté et les allemands
reconnaissez chez nous cette fermeté il
avait même une formule il disait
l'europe est géré par merkozy ceux qui
voulaient bien dire que la france était
partie prenante de la construction
européenne
depuis nous avons vécu le break si nous
avons vécu des vagues migratoires
exceptionnelle et nous avons vu certains
pays de l'est basculer dans le populisme
et l'extrême droite
est ce que ça ne vous suffit pas pour ne
pas se poser la question de ne pas
laisser filer une europe qui ne
ressemble en rien aux pères fondateurs
et à leur rêve européen
oui je crois que effectivement on peut
concilier monnaies et seguin et on peut
dire que cette europe doit se construire
pas à pas mais pas aux dépens de la
france pas ou des plantes des nations
pas aux dépens des peuples entre la
sortie de l'euro de madame le pen et le
fédéralisme de monsieur macron
finalement il ya un juste milieu ça
déplaît pas aux centristes le juste
milieu
surtout quand il est porté avec
conviction et avec force notre combat
c'est aussi et je devrais pas dire aussi
je devrais dire surtout la france et les
français ne l'oublions jamais n'oublions
jamais d'où nous venons nous sommes les
héritiers de ces paysages de ces villes
de ces villages de ses remparts et de
ses clochers nous sommes les héritiers
privilégié d'une histoire qui a fait ce
que nous sommes
parce que nous sommes effectivement les
héritiers du sacre de reims et les
héritiers de la fête de la fédération
nous sommes les héritiers des héros des
savons des artistes des écrivains et
leurs talents et leurs sacrifices nous
oblige
héritier des grecs qui nous ont appris
le tragique de la vie et en même temps
la démocratie et donc l'égalité hérité
de la chrétienneté qui nous a appris
l'amour de l'autre et donc la fraternité
héritiers aussi des philosophes des
lumières qui nous ont apporté a pris
cette arrogance française mais qui à ce
goût de la liberté que nous avons réussi
à diffuser dans toute l'europe et dans
le monde entier
cet héritage c'est notre culture
et j'ose dire
autre identité culturelle nous sommes le
peuple libre et rebelle qui permet de
dire quelles que soient nos origines nos
religions avec une fierté indicible je
suis français je suis français parce que
au fond de moi j'ai une certaine idée du
bonheur
peut-être aussi de l'amour et de la
liberté oui j'ai une certaine idée de la
france
comme le disait le général de gaulle et
je ne la sacrifierons pas à une
mondialisation financière
oui j'ai une certaine idée de l'homme
qui je ne la sacrifierons pas non plus
au mode ou libéralisme culturel
quelle que soit la mode
quels que soient les sondages nous
continuerons à dire que l'enfant ne
s'achète pas sur internet qu'un ventres
de femmes seules ou pas et que les
enfants ne sont pas des marchandises que
l'on peut commander et puis rejetée je
continuerai à défendre la décline la
dignité de l'homme la dignité de l'homme
ça ne décline pas avec nos forces
il n'y a pas des gens qui sont moins
digne parce qu'ils sont près de la mort
la dignité au contraire c'est leur
visage c'est ce visage de la fragilité
et de l'humanité qui finie et bien cette
dignité humaine souvenons nous toujours
qu'elle n'est pas l'estiment de soi
qu'elle n'est pas l'orgueil de se
regarder dans une glace
elle est inhérente à l'humanité et nous
le défendrons jusqu'au bout voilà le
débat que nous avons apportées ce débat
exigeant
nous allons le porter ensemble pour toi
avec toi le voile aventure que laurent
wauquiez vous propose aujourd'hui je
m'engage à aider à construire avec vous
ce nouveau projet pour la république et
pour la france
merci
[Applaudissements]